منتصر كنا معك قبل قليل كنا نشاهد ال
الاليات حتى وجودكم في المكان كان خطر
ماذا عن الوضع
الان بالفعل عبد القادر ولا زال الخطر
يحدق الحقيقه بالمكان الذي نتواجد فيه
وهذا الامر يحول على الاقل دون ظهورنا
امام الكاميرا لان كل العمارات المحيطه
بنا يعتليها جنود الاحتلال القناصه الذي
يجري في الخليل وما يظهر في هذه الصوره
هذا منزل الشهيد حسن قفيشه الذي نفذ عمليه
اطلاق نار مع الشهيدين عبد القادر
القواسمي ونصر الله القواسمه في السادس
عشر من نوفمبر الماضي عند حاجز النفق جنوب
القدس هذه العمليه ادت الى مقتل جندي
اسرائيلي واصابه سبعه اخرين قبل نحو ثلاثه
اسابيع قوات الاحتلال هدمت منزلي الشهيدين
عبد القادر القواسم ونصر الله القواسم
وهذه الليله هي تقوم في هذه اللحظات ومنذ
حوالي ساعتين بالحفر بالج الدران الداخليه
لهذه الشقه السكنيه التي تظهر في هذه
العماره هذه عماره سكنيه عبد القادر الشقه
التي سيتم تفجيرها هي في الطابق الرابع
فوق هذه الشقه طابقين واسفل هذه الشقه
ثلاثه طوابق وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن عمليه
تفجير ستكون على الاقل صعبه نحن نتحدث
ايضا عن عمارات ايضا سكنيه ملاصقه تماما
لهذه العماره ونحن نتحدث عن عدد كبير من
العمارات وتواجد جنود الاحتلال ايضا الذي
يظهر في هذه الصوره ايضا بمحيط المنزل
الذي يتم الحفر بداخله قوات الاحتلال
اغلقت كافه المداخل المؤديه الى هذه
العماره او الى هذه الشقه السكنيه ونسمع
بين الفينه والاخرى اطلاق قنابل الصوت
والرصاص الحي وحتى قنابل الغاز السام
المسيل للدموع وصلتنا رائحه الغاز قبل
قليل الى حيث المكان الذي نتواجد فيه
رائحه قويه هذا ناتج عن استخدام قوات
الاحتلال لقنابل الغاز والرصاص الحي
وقنابل الصوت اي ب او الذي اطلق النار
باتجاه الشبان الذين يتواجدون عند النقاط
التي تتواجد عليها قوات الاحتلال وتغلق
الطرق المؤديه الى هذه الشقه السكنيه هذا
البيت الثالث في الخليل الذي سيهدم في اقل
من شهر فيما هنالك ايضا منزلين اخرين
مختارين في بلده بني نعيم شرق الخليل هذه
المنازل تعود لاسيرين من عائله زيدات
نفذوا عمليه رعنانا في تل ابيب قبل حوالي
شهر اسفرت هذه العمليه عن مقتل اسرائيليه
واصابه 18 اخرين قوات الاحتلال اخطرت هذين
المنزلين بالهدم لكن لم لم تهدم هذه
المنازل حتى هذه اللحظه الهدم هذه الليله
لمنزل الشهيد حسن قفيشه الذي نفذ كما
ذكرنا مع عبد القادر القواسمي ونصر الله
القواسمي عمليه حاجز النفق جنوبي القدس لا
تزال قوات الاحتلال ايضا تتواجد في محيط
المكان في الخليل هذه الليله عبد القادر
شهدت مناطق اخرى اقتحام بلده السموع جنوب
الخليل شهدت اقتحاما موسعا مدينه يطا جنوب
الخليل شهده اقتحاما موسعا وحلحول شمال
الخليل ايضا هنالك تسير لدوريات وجنود
مشافي الشارع الرئيسي لحلح وتفتيش لمنازل
المواطنين لم نبلغ حتى اللحظه عن اي حالات
اعتقال او اصابات في المناطق الثلاث التي
ذكرتها حلحول والسموع ويطا التي تشهد
اقتحام بالتزامن مع المداهمه التي نحن في
صدد نقل صورتها الان وسط الخليل هذا حي
الجامعه وسط مدينه الخليل وهذا حي يعج
بالسكان والعمارات نم السكنيه المزدحمه
وسيجري التفجير بالتاكيد هذه الليله في ظل
هذا الوجود الكثيف لهذه العمارات وهذه
الشقق السكنيه عبد القادر منتصر نصار من
الخليل شكرا جزيلا
لك